hi everyone sal khan here from khan
academy welcome to our daily homeroom
live stream this is a thing we started
well it seems like a long time ago now
but it was several weeks ago when the
school closures happened just a way to
continue to support you as a parent a
teacher a student obviously khan academy
has a lot of resources like that but
there's something especially in this
time of social distancing about being
able to connect people live and some
days it's just me and it's here i'm here
to answer your questions and some days
we have incredible guests like today and
so today our guest is going to be
general stan mcchrystal i'm going to be
bringing him on a little bit but i'll
tell you all ahead of time whether
you're on facebook or youtube start
thinking of questions that you would
like to ask the general and put them in
there we have khan academy team members
who are looking at those questions and
we'll surface them to myself and uh
general mcchrystal
i do like to remind everyone somewhat uh
because it's important that we are not
for profit we are funded by
philanthropic donations from folks like
yourself we were running at a deficit
even before this covid crisis hit and
now with the school closures we're
seeing our traffic be almost 3x of what
it typically is our registrations are uh
depending on the day 6 to 20 x of of
what we would normally expect to be and
we're trying to do more programs so if
you're in a position to do so please
think about donating i do want to give a
special shout out to several
corporations who've stepped up in the
last few weeks
bank of america google.org att novartis
and fastly to help us help you hopefully
with what's going on with school
closures but we are still running at a
deficit and we still need more help so
whether you're an individual giver or a
corporation or representative
corporation
uh please please think about that
so with that i'd like to bring on
general stan mcchrystal
and uh you know general you're one of
those people uh you're you're you're a
very decorated person in your career i
could i could probably read your bio for
about five minutes but the headlines you
are retired four-star general you ran
essentially a significant fraction of
some of the uh or all of the u.s
military operations in uh that we've
been in in recent modern history uh and
since then you have gone into the
private sector and you are focused on
helping advise folks on things like
leadership and organizational structure
did i get that generally right
well you probably gave me more credit
than i deserve i was part of the team
but yeah you're pretty accurate
so so maybe a good place to start you
know there's a lot of young people who
are watching this and they're always
thinking about their careers they're
thinking about how do i navigate life
how do i build a sense of leadership
if you could just walk us through your
career arc starting from when you were
maybe a a high school student but
especially once you got into the
military and also a lot of us don't
fully understand how the military
hierarchy works and what are the
expectations as you become a lieutenant
as you become a fir a one-star general
two-star how does that work
sure yeah i mean you only kind of
figured out in the rearview mirror i
grew up in an army family my father was
a soldier
and his father was a soldier and my four
brothers all were in the army and my
sister married a soldier then when i
married my wife she was the daughter of
a career soldier and her three brothers
were all so you kind of get it we were
the army business
from the earliest stage i can remember i
wanted to be a soldier like my father
because my father was my hero he was a
very low-key guy a decorated combat
veteran but very self-evasive very quiet
um
and so he was my idea the model of a
leader so i wanted to do what he did and
go to west point so at age 17 i went to
west point now that was 1972 and to put
it in context the military wasn't very
popular in 1972 the end of the vietnam
war
so statistically speaking it was the
easiest year in the academy's entire
history to be admitted so here i am
so i so i got into the academy and
i wanted to be an infantry officer
and west point was 170 years old when i
re when i entered and they took
themselves very seriously and i thought
west point was going to be sort of just
a turn style i go through to get to my
career and i didn't take it very
seriously and so we had this clash of
cultures me and west point 17 year old
stan and 170 year old west point you can
guess who won
and so for four years i had kind of a
rough go of it first couple years i did
horribly in discipline i did horribly in
academics almost flunked out and then my
last two years i started dating this
girl
uh annie who i've now been married to
for 43 years and she sort of set me
straight and i i started improving on
those things
but you come out of west point
basically
schooled in things like character and a
college education you're not a trained
soldier
and so the first thing you do is you go
to some initial courses and your desire
is to become technically and tactically
competent you want to know weapons you
want to know tactics you want to be able
to land navigate so that when you go to
your first
leadership job
as a platoon leader you know you'll be
respected you'll be effective
so i went through about eight or nine
months of additional training schools to
include ranger school where they sort of
try to break you down and then if you
don't break
you get this ranger tab and you go
forward but i got to my first unit in
the 82nd as the second lieutenant and it
was the 70s army and it wasn't very good
and it was still kind of vietnam
hangover and and the troops
most of them came from a difficult
background
and so you walk in a college graduate
trained and you think okay i'm going to
lead these people
and then you realize that in fact they
know an awful lot
and although they would do some amazing
things on weekends
they they actually take care of you
you take care of them but when it really
gets to doing business they take care of
you so from an early age you learn
that the fight is going to be won by the
sergeants and the privates
the lieutenant is going to enable them
to win it
and that gets more true the further you
go up so you spend the first i spent
four years as a lieutenant leading first
about 30 soldiers as a platoon as a
paratrooper lieutenant
and then i went to special forces and
led a team of special forces
non-commissioned officers green berets
your next number first on that first
appointment i am curious you know you
were probably what 23 24 when you were
leading that group 22 23. yeah and i'm
guessing most of them were your age
maybe even a few of them were older than
you how did you handle that like did you
ever feel like an imposter syndrome or
you know how am i going to get the
respect of these folks
well it's very interesting you do the
first thing is you wonder are they going
to mind me are they going to respect me
but it was really kind of a dangerous
thing because
what would happen was the
non-commissioned officers would be more
experienced and they'd have to be sort
of up the hard asses
and the private sector what does that
mean what does non-commissioned officer
mean
means sergeant so
you have commissioned officers which are
lieutenants up through generals and
non-commissioned means you're an officer
but with not no commission so it's
sergeants it's from sergeant e5 up
through sergeant major and then below
that are privates and specialists we
call them are corporals
so the the military's broken into
enlisted ranks and officer ranks
and typically people enter as a private
or they enter as a lieutenant now some
people will be listed and become an
officer
but that the traditional way is to come
in at those two
so as you're a 22 year old lieutenant
you've got sergeants who are combat
veterans who have been around the block
and they have got to be
the the biggest sticklers for discipline
and standards in the platoon
and yet you want to be in charge so it's
this interesting dynamic you have to
earn their respect
but you're not
really as qualified or as knowledgeable
as they are
good platoon sergeants you have a
platoon leader and then a senior
sergeant
sergeant first class he's responsible or
he feels he's responsible for training
you for developing you and if you get
the right
relationship it gets very close and the
lieutenant learns to keep their mouth
shut
learns to to let the platoon sergeant
guide them but the platoon sergeant also
learns increasingly to let the
lieutenant take more and more
responsibility now when you're young you
can make some big mistakes i i made some
very bad mistakes as a second lieutenant
at one point i started listening to the
privates
when they would complain about
the the sergeants to me i shouldn't have
been listened to him about that
but they would complain about him and
they'd go you know lt those sergeants
really are pain in the ass aren't they
and
if you give them that ear and you start
to think wow they like me they don't
like the sergeants so i'm actually a
good leader
that's exactly the wrong conclusion
because what really the reality was
they're
you know they're wily people and they
are creating sort of a division
and
it takes a little much it took me some
maturity to sort of grow through that
era
before i uh
i really learned
how you lead
another time
or we all have times when you learn
about standards once we went to this
position and i was i was pretty
demanding because i i wanted to have
high standards we went to this position
and i was leading a mortar platoon
and i made them dig the mortars in which
takes several hours three or four hours
of really hard work for the whole
platoon and we dug them in and then we
went to open the range with the range
control who allows you to live fire
and they told us you're in the wrong
position
and i said wait a minute and it was my
fault i had read the papers wrong
so i had him digging in the wrong
position i went to range control i said
would you please let us change so that
we don't have to move and they said nope
and so i had to go back to the platoon
and say we have to move
it was dark it was cold it was starting
to rain and i wasn't very popular i said
fill the holes in which they did we went
to the new location and then you had
this moral question
am i going to have them dig in because i
said that's always the standard
but because of my screw-up they were
going to have to do it a second time
and i remember that night i said okay
we're going to dig in we're going to do
it again and there was muttering and
there was hate and discontent
and the only thing i can do was yeah i
got in and dug with them of course
but you know you just go through that
and you learn that you're going to make
mistakes and you've got to own up to
them you got to get to look people in
their eye and take them
yeah
i could dig into each of these segments
because i think there's so much there
but sorry i just i and we're starting to
have a lot of questions coming but
continue with that narrative i mean and
some of this stuff you're saying very
nonchalantly like yeah and then i
started leading some special forces i
mean my understanding of special forces
these are very hardcore
types of training and and uh
and
you know you do these things to test
yourself too you want to be in elite
units because you want to see can i do
that
plus you want to serve with really good
people so i went to special forces
and uh then i went to this advanced
course for a year where they really
trained you to go from lieutenant to
captain at about the four-year point
and then i went as a captain you're a
company commander now company commander
leads about 150 soldiers
and so at this level you're leading
essentially four platoons so you're a
platoon leader with 30 40 people now
you're a company commander about 150 and
you have four platoons
now you're sort of
minor level of executive leadership
but you are supposed to be much more
mature now in fact behind your back
they'll even call a company commander at
age 25 or sex the old man
uh yeah i was very centralized as a
company commander my first company i had
a mechanized infantry company of 14
armored vehicles i put them all on the
same radio frequency so that i said turn
left they all turn left at exactly the
same time
and it was a small enough organization
where i could micromanage it
you know kind of
put my fingerprints on everything
and then i moved to another company
command i went to the ranger regiment
where it's a more elite light infantry
force
and the non the sergeants
there are very very capable when i got
there in 1985 they were very good at
their jobs
and they wouldn't tolerate
micromanagement and so i got in there
and i was sort of hard charged i said
okay here's what we're going to do and i
started micromanaging and i got this
incredible pushback
i mean i got in your face kind of push
back because they'd seen a lot of
company commanders and they weren't
particularly impressed with me
and they said we don't operate that way
we are competent to do this step back
and let us do our jobs
and you know it sort of started my
journey of saying you know
okay and when they forced me to do that
we performed far better
and so that began
started an arc in my career where i
started
understanding that my role wasn't to do
things it wasn't even really to make a
lot of decisions it was to create an
environment
when really competent people
could be really good at what they do
you're you're sort of then you do some
years on the staff
uh i went to the first gulf war and
things like that but the next big level
is a battalion commander
and
that's about 600 soldiers
you're a lieutenant colonel you got
about 17 years in service and you've got
a staff of about 35 officers and then
600 soldiers i had paratroopers
in
my first battalion
and now you kind of are the old man
now you are
pretty darn experienced
you've got a staff to make things happen
and yet you're still close enough to
these 600 soldiers where you know most
of them by by sight and name at least
and you can lead
by example
most officers will tell you that's one
of their favorite experiences because
it's a big enough organization to
actually do a lot and you get to do a
lot of professional development
but you're still young enough to be
vigorous and and leading from the front
and deeply
deeply involved in it
every rank after that you start to get
further from the soldiers
when you command a brigade you get about
3 000
soldiers
and you've got battalion commanders
between you and them and you're still
the commander but the reality is you're
starting to be of a greater distance
you're starting to be a resource
provider you're starting to be someone
who shapes policy
and then as a general officer that's
really what you do you you lead by
inspiration and guidance but you are
shaping things for the people who
actually get stuff done
and what's the difference people hear
about
one star two-star three-star four-star
general is there a difference between
like what what is what what divides
those lines yeah that's a really fair
question um
by law the army usually has 303 general
officers half of whom have to be one
stars brigadier general
so there are the four levels of general
officer except in world war ii when they
had five
one star general typically
you're about 23 24 years in service
you've been very successful because it's
a real eye of the needle they select 40
people to be generals each year
out of about 2600 candidates
so only 40 people in a year group that
enter in in a year
get up and and ever make one star
one stars are operational they serve on
some staffs they're assistant division
commanders
two star commanders major generals
command
divisions they command that's about 15
000 people
they are operational commanders
and then although they don't talk about
it there's really a big difference
between two star generals and three
because three star generals is a pretty
small group i think it's about 50 in the
army
and they
run big things they run cores of 40 and
50 000 people they run agencies
in the government they do huge jobs and
then above that there's this another big
jump to four stars and they're typically
12 to 14 four stars
and four stars run
the the army completely in the defense
department
um four stars have immense power
all of the general officers have a lot
of power but
it it's kind of like the richter scale
your your relative influence goes up
much more dramatically at the three and
four star level
wow no i could ask more i mean i'm
learning a lot just about how the
military's structured i've always been
fascinated by this but i want to make
sure i get some questions from uh from
youtube and from facebook a lot of
people are asking a lot of good
questions you know so from facebook
jenny evans and this this is kind of a
good balance between your military world
and what you're not doing in the private
sector
how do we respond to poor leadership
so i guess this could be a situation
where you know maybe your leader is how
do you how do you manage around that or
maybe someone in your organization isn't
leading well
yeah that that's always one of the
toughest questions if you're in an
organization let's say you're in the
middle of it and the leadership above
you is not effective
it doesn't motivate you or it doesn't
get the task done well
it's really hard to march into your
boss's office and say ma'am or sir
you're not doing a good job you need to
do x x and x it's easy to say you do
that but most of us don't receive that
kind of visitor very well if we're a
leader
what i think we do is several things
first is we
personify being a good follower first
because then leaders will appreciate you
and they'll listen to you more
second
reflect the leadership behaviors you
want to see in your bosses
don't try to make it a difference don't
don't in front of that the people in the
organization don't try to make yourself
look better than your boss because it's
just it's disrespectful and not helpful
but then have the kind of conversations
that say
ma'am or sir
this is what i think might work better
as we approach something but again i
would tell you
put yourself in their position
don't be self-righteous
leaders are under often under a lot of
pressure maybe sometimes they don't see
it if you say it in a way where they are
receptive when you're communicating i
think you have a much better uh chance
than uh
you know being more negative
i like that a lot like you don't want to
just immediately you know create a
stereotype around someone climb the
ladder of inference and then somehow
become insubordinate or try to embarrass
them that's just going to make it worse
uh try to try to empathize a bit but but
speak your mind in an appropriate way
so a lot of questions about raising kids
here around leadership from youtube
waquina m and then adnan aziz is asking
variations of the same question what
advice do you have to raise kids who
think for themselves and become leaders
versus someone who will only do what
they are told
yeah
well you certainly want your children to
think for themselves because you're not
going to be there with them
i would say the first thing about
leading you know raising kids as a form
of leadership
is reflect the values that you want i've
told people this before but i i had this
wonderful father and mother and in my
entire childhood i never saw either of
them do anything
dishonest i never saw him take a parking
place they couldn't have i never saw him
you know take a wink in a nod and keep
changed when it was given back too much
was given to him at a store um that just
everything i saw them do was be kind to
people
be respectful to people and even to us
as kids so you start by being people
that the kids admire and would like to
be like i think after that when you've
got your kids
each kid is different i mean that's the
thing we have to understand my son
he grew up and he's very much his own
guy and i was a soldier and i was you
know pretty focused and whatnot and in
high school he had shoulder-length hair
and
you know
i never gave him a hard time about it i
laughed with him i said sometimes i'm
keeping pictures of this and when you
get older you know we have a good fun
and then he had a mohawk through college
he was seven years getting a four-year
degree he had a mohawk of different
colors
he was a guitarist lead guitarist in a
punk rock band terrible music
but they were pretty successful i mean
they made cds and toured and all
but what the way i did it was i
maintained the relationship the whole
time
i never tried to say you should be a
soldier i never tried to say i just said
great you know you don't do that you
know i joked about us here but um
we just i thought maintaining the
relationship was going to be more
important than anything else
now he's a works for the us government
and an intel agency you know who knew
and he's a father of three
daughters so i say life comes around to
pay you back for your youth
your son's youth sounds a little bit
like some of mine i tried to grow
shoulder-length hair but my um it turned
more into kind of a sphere
so from youtube there's a sixth grade
teacher virginia garrett asks what is
the most difficult part of being a
leader and what would you tell a high
school child about being a leader
yeah
i got an easy answer for this the most
disciplined part is self-discipline if
all of us took a piece of paper right
now and wrote down those things we think
good leaders do
we'd end up with some pretty similar
lists
and then if we all looked at that list
and said what do we in our lives
actually do
our lists we'd probably have to strike a
few things off because good leadership
is sometimes inconvenient
it's sometimes frightening it's
sometimes awkward
and so
the difference in my view between good
leaders and not good leaders
is almost never ability or charisma or
celebrity
it's the self-discipline to do to do
what you know you ought to do
and
because that's hard because it's all the
time i used to when i was a four star
you go around we had 150 000 troops
under my command and up afghanistan i'd
go around and i'd interact with a bunch
of soldiers that i would only see once
they'd only meet the four star one time
probably in their lives
and i'd have these interactions
and i would try very hard to remember
that however that interaction was they
were going to write or call home that
night and tell their spouse about it
if it was a good interaction if i
treated them respectfully and you know
that sort of thing they'd write and say
hey i met general crystal it was great
if i act a fool
they're going to call a ride home and
they're not going to say that they're
going to say something else and it's not
my reputation i think about it's the
reality that
that interaction is important enough for
them to to call home about it's
important enough for me to be
disciplined with
so that i treat them the way they ought
to be now i didn't always get it right
you get tired you get frustrated you get
angry and i interact with somebody and
as soon as it was over i know i blew
that
and then at the end of the night you go
and you're you're going to bed
and you carry this sense of guilt you
say
i wasn't the leader i should have been
today
but you don't say okay that's the new
normal i'm just going to lapse into that
what you do is say i'm going to try to
do it better tomorrow
and that is the best leaders i've known
are never so self-confident in their
leadership that they just kind of go
around and let everybody bask in it
they they agonize over it i think that's
important
yeah i mean what i get from that is two
things discipline being able to do the
things that you intellectually know are
right even if you don't
want to do them or if they're
uncomfortable and then the second thing
is to just be constantly self-reflective
and not rigid in in who you are let your
i guess you let your ego drive things is
is what i'm hearing a a theme throughout
all of this
this is a question about leadership from
actually from poland
rafale molech harodiski asked what is
the right balance between challenging
people and caring about them and yeah
this would apply to leadership it might
even reply to parenting
yeah they used to say in the military
and i think it was irwin rommel first
said the best form of troop welfare is
first class training
and so what i would tell people is you
don't have to be easy on people you can
be extraordinarily demanding you can
push people hard you can make their life
challenging and that can be the best
thing you can do for them
now you don't have to be a jerk about it
you don't have to be ugly about it but
you can force people to do things they
didn't think they could do in fact the
leaders i remember most fondly
that i owe the most to were people who
were actually pretty hard on me i always
felt like i had to be
really working hard to meet their
expectations
but most of them also had a personality
where it was desperately important for
me to meet their expectations meaning i
respected them enough
that their approval was something that
mattered to me
but i would never shy away sometimes we
think we got to be popular sometimes we
think we've got to be rubbing them on
the belly you know our people on the
belly all the time and saying don't work
too hard etc
no we got to get people ready for the
real world and the real world is
challenging
and so in the real world
they're going to have to do it so i
think we owe them that
right you could be hard on someone as
long as they know in the heart of hearts
that you're doing it for
what's best for them versus your own ego
or you're just trying to
not be good about it
so a lot i mean there's a ton of
questions this is great um there you
know uh this is interesting beth otto
from facebook asks what was your biggest
challenge as a leader in your career and
how did you overcome it
um
yeah that's an interesting question i
had a lot of challenges um
i think the first was being a
micromanager and i kind of got people
beat that out of me
and that was good another thing is i am
by nature very very introverted
and so um
because of that i i
i think if i die and and go to hell
it'll be an endless cocktail party we're
gonna make small talk so
for me
it is being comfortable engaging with
people now i'm usually better engaging
with people i work with soldiers and all
because i know my role but it was
something i had to work at i'm not
naturally gregarious and backslapping
and and hanging around a lot of people
so that was uh
really important to me and then
i also find that when i get tired i get
short-tempered um and it's really it's
more impatient i never yell or do that
kind of thing but what i do is i just
get curt
and if i if i get pushed hard and i get
that way i'll start being very short
with people most of whom don't deserve
it
you know i've been lucky to have people
work around me remarkably tolerable
about it because they'll know at a
certain point yeah he's getting tired
all right
he's starting to be
the bad stand
but but it's in
it's important for me to to constantly
remind myself about that
well were there times just following off
on that question especially when you
talked about it when you were in kind of
the earlier ranks in the military but
once you were
you know a four-star general and you you
you are
you know you are deciding on things that
could affect thousands of people's or or
even geopolitics broadly were there
times where you questioned yourself or
you just really said i don't know if i'm
making the right decision or you you
kind of stayed up at night and just said
the consequences are so huge that it was
it was paralyzing for you
yeah most nights
you would make decisions where you sent
people into a an operation where you
know
a number of them are going to get killed
or wounded
and you just wonder if you've done it
right
those are
are difficult
but sometimes others are even more
difficult when you've got to fire
somebody that you've known a long time
and they're a good person they're
working hard they're just not right for
this
um i would agonize over these those
things tremendously i remember there was
a much you know reported in the media
when i was a four star in afghanistan i
recommend it to the president that we
deploy additional troops we expand our
ability to operate
and the president approved it
and i remember right after we approved
that
you know i
went into this reflective mood and i
said okay i've just
asked for 40 000 more soldiers
a percentage of whom are gonna
are going to be killed
what did i do
and you know i was able to come back to
this and say well i used my best
judgment i think it was right and i do
think it was right to this day
but i ask myself those kinds of question
all the time
would it have been easier or better not
to have
and it's not the heat or the the
the public or media pressure that
bothers you it's the mirror pressure
when you look in the mirror
did i do the right thing
that i thought was right that
was it my best judgment do i really
believe that i did the right thing for
the right reason
and how do you that's a fascinating
tension for me you know how do you
maintain that humanity where you're like
wow these are 40 000 lives you know
they're not only going to leave their
family but some of them might be killed
or injured in other ways
lifelong consequences and so the
empathetic side that could be almost
paralyzing to just think about that idea
but at the end at the other day you have
a job you have to be rational about it
you have to be kind of calculating um
do you sometimes feel like you heard too
much on one side of that
or the other
i i think i always was thinking about
that there were days when i thought i i
aired one way or another
um you know ulysses grant was famous for
pushing the
uh the union army so hard and causing so
many casualties he would not visit field
hospitals
because when he went to the hospitals
and he saw the tremendous carnage that
he was responsible for
he thought it made him lose his resolve
and yet he had concluded that the best
thing he could do with the nation was
lower his head and just go on and win
even though the costs in the near term
would be high
i think
i think you make those balances all the
time
because particularly in the military the
force exists
to prosecute american policy
and if that requires us to put it in
harm's way that's what it's for
you just have got to balance it against
being
a cavalier
or doing it for the wrong reasons we're
not having done enough due diligence on
it there are a number of things as a
military professional you better be
asking yourself
because people look to you and they ask
you do we need to do that and you based
on your experience have enough respect
usually from that group that they listen
and so
you need to be very careful about what
you
what you suggest
yeah this is fascinating we're already
out of time we could go on you know
hopefully we can get you on this again
uh we have a lot of uh questions for
uh the message actually let's finish
with one question which i think is
relevant to the time we're living in
with you know the social distancing and
and covet and all that uh this is from
youtube brian 10 ache asks what advice
can you offer for projecting calm
controlled confidence in a crisis yeah a
lot of times you know that stuff is
going on but people are looking at you
to and your temperament to figure out
what's going on
in in a firefight as soon as it starts
the privates look to the sergeants to
see how they ought to act if the
privates haven't been in one before so
they're looking to see what are the
sergeants doing should i be scared what
should i do
even though they've been trained
in what to do they're looking for
example that's what leaders should do so
i would say the first thing is
show calm
that doesn't mean you should minimize
the problem you know there's this
tension that says should i tell my
people
how serious this really is am i just
going to scare them or should i project
this overconfidence
no i would be very candid with the team
say this is the situation
however
we are committed to getting through this
we are committed to succeeding in this
effort following through
and
provide inspiration say there we're
going to get through this and after that
we're going to go on to to what we were
trying to do so the leader
provides this candor
grounding in reality provides this
confidence confident commitment that
says like franklin roosevelt did in his
first inaugural address he said we're
going to implement this new deal we're
going to try a whole bunch of things and
some of them won't work
we'll stop those but we're going to
figure out what works and go through it
and suddenly provided hope to the
american people
you don't ever want to say it's going to
be easier than it's going to be because
then you lose your credibility when it's
not
and so i think that the leaders play an
incredible role during this period
even though we might not have the right
answer
you know we might say hey i'm not sure
what we ought to do but i know we're
going to figure it out and we're going
to stick with it
till we get to the place we need to be
yeah
i'm ready to follow you
gentlemen crystal
uh so so thank you so much i think this
was i mean i could see from the the
message boards i mean this was this was
really uh useful for for a lot of folks
and uh thank you for for for joining us
i hope we can do this again sometime
soon well you're kind to having me
selling thanks for all you guys do with
the khan academy it's amazing
great thank you
thanks
so thanks everyone for joining hopefully
you found that as interesting as i did
obviously you know it's a shame that
some of these only last half an hour a
little bit more but we'll try to get
more time with all of these folks that i
think we can all learn a ton from uh
i'll just remind you we're gonna be
doing this every day uh and so
come on next week we're gonna have a
couple of sessions with just me i'm
happy to answer any questions you all
have about anything and we're also going
to have a we have a pretty fun lineup
we're getting a lot of momentum with
really incredible guests uh like we've
had obviously we had ray dalio yesterday
we have general uh stan mcchrystal today
and uh next week we continue with this
cast of really incredible folks that i
think we can all learn from i'll remind
everyone again we are not for profit if
you're in a position to do so please
think about donating to khan academy
it's those philanthropic donations that
allow us to do what we're doing and we
are running at a deficit right now
especially as we're trying to support
the world
in our own way through the school
closures that are going on right now but
with that hope everyone has a good and
safe weekend and i will see you all next
week
you